good morning hick it's Tuesday so almost
all books get worse over time like the
classic example of this is the work of
John Dos pasos who 70 years ago was
considered one of the Great American
novelists and now we hardly read his
work and that's not because his books
weren't good then it's because they
aren't as good now times and people
change and unexpected and unpredictable
ways and books that are useful to us in
some moments are less useful than others
but occasionally very occasionally a
book starts out good and then gets
better alright so let's look at two
examples of this phenomenon first we
have the Great Gatsby which was mostly
forgotten within a couple years of its
publication in 1925. many critics felt
that Gatsby was inferior to F Scott
Fitzgerald's previous work especially
the Beloved this side of paradise
probably the most famous critic in
America at the time H.L Menken called
Gatsby obviously unimportant the New
York Herald called it a book for the
season only and Fitzgerald was
devastated that it only sold about
twenty thousand copies by the time he
died about 15 years later The Great
Gatsby wasn't even for sale at most
bookstores and yet it turned out not to
be a book for the season only because
Gatsby has a lot to say about class and
inequality and The American Dream all
subjects that would become more poignant
and interesting in the context of the
Great Depression and then World War II
and then the post-war era another
example if you look at the best-selling
science fiction and fantasy novels of
the 1990s you will not find Octavia
Butler's parable of the sower it did not
make the New York Times bestseller list
until 27 years after its initial
publication and 14 years after its
author's death parable of the sower is a
novel narrated by a young black woman
living in a future America where systems
are collapsing the president is a
demagogue climate change is wreaking
havoc there's a substance abuse epidemic
and other things that feel just a little
contemporary now parable of the sower
was critically acclaimed when it came
out out but I think it has gotten better
over the last 30 years because it helps
us to understand that much of our now
wasn't just foreseeable it was foreseen
its Explorations about how to unify
polarized communities and collaborate
across difference are profoundly
instructive for us also like Gatsby it's
just a great story anyway Hank I bring
all this up because I have recently come
to understand that your two book series
an absolutely remarkable thing and a
beautifully foolish Endeavor are
examples of books that are getting
better over time now I want to be very
clear that I am not comparing you to F
Scott Fitzgerald or Octavia Butler Hank
but when I first read your books like I
did love them I thought they were
incredibly fun adventure stories with a
lot to say about contemporary internet
culture and especially about Fame you
articulated things about celebrity and
the fracturing of attention that I'd
never seen in a book before but in the
years since yearbooks were first
published I've realized that they are
also about a lot of other things that I
just didn't know about yet they explore
for instance how certain wealthy
individuals can form complicated
symbiotic relationships with groups of
people who feel angry and
disenfranchised to create divisive
Affinity networks you explored how
sudden dramatic technological shifts can
be overwhelming and disorienting and
destructive even as they are also
thrilling and promising in short at
least so far as your books have gotten
older they feel more and more
contemporary which is pretty astonishing
God it's just so weird that my brother
wrote those books anyway Hank I hope
that 2023 will be a year when you
somehow find some spare minutes to write
because I really love your writing so
I'll be taking next week off meaning
that this is my last vlogbrothers video
of 2022 and I want to end the year with
some weird news for you on January 1st
2023 vlogbrothers will be old enough to
drive a car in the United States
how strange and how lovely
Hank I'll see you on Friday